Have you ever wondered why the Chinese are always migratoryly successful Why
they always succeed What they do that ensures their migratory success
Because many Chinese have migrated In fact in my opinion I think they are
the largest colony of migrants in the world but
they are often migratoryly successful.
I have never seen 1 Chinese in front of a supermarket waiting to get
something or at 1 traffic light waiting to get 1 handout In fact I have
never seen 1 Chinese waiting for 1 help from the state And I think the key
and what we can learn from them is that they have a migratory culture that
they understand that the migrant must have 1 way of life and that is where
the key to the migratory culture resides El Chino
no Chinese is waiting to be given,
Chinese is going to contribute,
Chinese is not going to live like others lives under his parameters,
under his standards,
focused on his goals and not waiting for dreams to come true
overnight He works tirelessly like ants he works day and night
focused on his goals focused on his project until he achieves it
and when he achieves it then he does something that many when he does.
I don't know if you know,
but in Chinese culture migrants support each other and
even lend themselves resources to undertake business.
And I ask you how many times or how many cases do you know of
people who have rather stepped on their feet to scrub another person?
The key to success is not only in achieving it yourself but also
in helping others to try to enhance the migratory success of others.
No,
what I want to be clear to you is that the migrant has to have 1 way of life
and that he must understand his condition as
a migrant to be successful migratory,
I hope this analogy helps you and helps
you build your migratory success 1 big hug.